denn es künstler arno breker war ein
sehr umstrittener künstler er war sogar
der lieblings bildhauer von adolf hitler
und jetzt wurden neue werke von ihm
gefunden
bei bauarbeiten im garten des
kunsthauses dahlem in berlin ist eine
skulptur von arno breker einem von
hitler sehr geschätzten künstler
entdeckt worden
eine zweite dort gefundene skulptur wird
noch zugeordnet
wir haben die schachtarbeiten
durchgeführt um diese abwasserleitung
zulegen und sind dann in die tiefe
vielleicht von 50 auf einen harten
gegenstand gestoßen wo wir erst dachten
es werden alte fundament weil wir öfter
schon mal alte fundamente oder alte
gesteins blöcke gefunden haben und
kratzte an diesen etwas härteren
gegenstand und dann hat mein kollege
sofort bemerkt dass dieser brocken nicht
beton ist sondern marmor nachdem die
nazis breakers arbeiten zunächst
skeptisch eingeschätzt hatten wurde er
gegen kriegsende von hitler und goebbels
auf der liste unersetzlicher künstler
geführt
das atelier in dem das kunsthaus dahlem
heute sitzt war als teil der von den
nazis gebauten hauptstadt germania für
breker gebaut worden weil die gefundenen
skulpturen lagen kopfüber im boden ich
hoffe dass wir mit dem man im
gesichtsbereich keine beschädigung
gemacht haben ich glaube die sind alle
weil die skulptur lag er mit dem gesicht
nach unten
dass wir hauptsächlich auf der rückseite
die ersten kontakte den ersten kontakt
hatten mit dir mit dem marmor die
plastiken sollen nun bis zum 15 januar
im kunsthaus dahlem ausgestellt werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren